Chelsea Handler
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
okay I'm always great to have you thank
you this is my congressman mine - ah
yeah nice to see you lobbying after the
show for our pet project one board don't
worry okay
what a great week to have you here
because with all this explosive news
about Bill O'Reilly we had learned some
interesting facts about sexual rights
before you move on to that may I
interposed Lee I'm Sean Spicer you know
when I think about him every day at
these White House briefings which I
enjoy thoroughly obviously I just
pictured him down at mar-a-lago you know
they made that pitch tent today and they
couldn't like in them because they don't
have a real gift so they made a fake one
and they're like oh yeah we have a
private room for security purposes
German moral Lagos sound like one of
those water parks that was closed down
because somebody swam in the pool with
an STD you know and he so he's like the
lifeguard yelling at everybody John I've
got any more practice by the pool yeah I
think so all right
but but women out there want to know we
learned this week exist a because Bill
O'Reilly's in there's that eighty
percent of women in America have
experienced sexual harassment in the
workplace and it's only down ten percent
since nineteen seventy six when it was
ninety percent have you Chelsea Handler
ever experienced sexual harassment in
the workplace
I've definitely sexually harassed I mean
Anna have you experienced it I think I'm
innocent category well I have to be very
honest because I don't want to make up a
story that's not true I have it first I
mean I don't know I'm sure it's happened
behind my back but I've never felt in a
position where I felt uncomfortable I
pity the fool who harassed you right
you're right I'd like to go work for
Bill O'Reilly actually for a day and a
half but I
what about the fact that no one wants to
[ __ ] up you I mean do you have any
girlfriends he's a very successful man
certainly somebody out there must want
to [ __ ] Bill O'Reilly we what gets me a
lot right let's try to reach out to it
that is very very yeah that is very
friendly of you but if you think about
it if you had to choose between him or
Roger Ailes I mean those are the two
people you have to choose from it's like
who would you rather I mean it's really
a [ __ ] show something
so what you tell I had done up to me I'm
not homosexual but Nancy Smith who is
represented gretchen carlson said going
to Human Resources in a company like Fox
is like going to the KGB to complain
about Putin and then Trump said that he
should have settled he defended Bill
O'Reilly he said he's a person I know
well [ __ ] Trump doesn't know Bill
O'Reilly well he talks to him on the air
a couple of times here that's that
knowing somebody I don't think builds
anything wrong [ __ ] again how the
[ __ ] would he know that
yeah but also he doesn't define that as
anything wrong to begin with I mean he
doesn't think that is wrong he's like
you should be able to grab women who
work for you that's fine but also
additionally I mean I like how many
advertisers are pulling out of Fox News
because soon they'll only have people
that are representing people who have
been sexually harassed by women on the
commercials for Fox News so it's a
perfect cycle for me all right so
another sexism news this week I learned
about something called the Billy Graham
rule that I wanted to ask you about now
I learned about this because of Mike
Mike Pence you know was a super-duper
Christian okay he but we know about this
right I'm not making this up and he has
these rules no eat this is called the
Billy Graham rules no eating alone with
a woman other than your wife no going to
a party where they're serving alcohol if
your wife isn't with you because most
women they get a drink in them and they
cannot control themselves from trying to
jump
yeah exactly I mean you've got a couple
of drinks in here Mike Pence was there
without his wife ah you couldn't control
yourself right I'll think about tomorrow
I'm [ __ ] you tonight that's what it
would be
come on not if it was a Friday no way I
wouldn't be able to control myself I'm
thinking about you know the whole Steve
Banta thing how it's the abandoned maybe
going away or you know there's a rewrite
what do you I'm like well they can't
replace him with a woman because Mike
Pence won't be allowed to be alone with
her alone either you know I mean there
is a serious part to this which is that
it affects women in the workplace if you
can't even have dinner with your boss
because you know you're not the wife
that affects you as a woman then you
can't get the boss's ear this this is so
Christian it's Muslim what
what about women though so does every
will apply to women who are also married
he can't have dinner meals with them
alone if they're married that's a good
question yeah but I mean it's [ __ ] up
all right so look let me ask you about
Jared and Ivanka because we didn't elect
them right right did we did we elect I
mean the list was a package deal really
the list of his Jared Kushner's
responsibilities diplomacy with Mexico
with China with Canada he went to Iraq
to advise about the war against Isis
brokering the Middle East peace he's
gonna do that in charge of trade deals
charges the White House Office of
American innovation reinventing
government infrastructure plan
modernizing the technology and data
infrastructure for federal departments
and agencies broadband internet
reimagining the Veterans Administration
solving the opioid epidemic spearheading
criminal justice reform then on Tuesday
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] Kelsey Han I mean we are
totally [ __ ] that guy better be a
vodka first of all evanka have sent a
message to all you know powerful women
across the world that if you work hard
then you show dedication and time to
your craft that you can get an unpaid
job as your dad's assistant five but why
he gets all these responsibilities why
why should success you don't understand
please someone is there anyone who can
explain that one man could do all this I
mean I remember not look at me
I always clean you with the real
purposes because this is something that
I saw while serving overseas as a CIA
officer and that is authoritarians put
their family members in critical
positions because they want control over
those things they don't want those
issues to be accountable to the people
and that's what the problem here and
that's exactly what that's exactly
what's happening with this event but the
good point is you know I've gotten so
far thus far hasn't shown any sort of I
mean influence that everybody's been
talking about oh she's gonna implement
gonna insert her pocket and her women's
whatever she's talking about I hope I
did too because she seems like a
reasonable person when you're sitting
next to Donald Trump right the problem
is is and if the Steve Bannon if the
rumors are true that Steve Bannon is
going to be removed from the White House
or and she has a part of that then you
know then maybe there is some good to be
had by having her there if she is
exerting her influence in that way then
I'm really then I'll take it I don't
care if it's a day late and a dollar
short I'll put her clothing line back in
Nordstrom whatever maybe not the whole
clothing line maybe the belts in the
shoes do not the whole thing but
if she can do a good thing like that
could Steve Bannon will work